I work all the time I have no Hobbies
that's all I do this is the life I want
to live I want to do big where I
want to go will be hard and treacherous
to get to comma and that's okay they're
like that's not healthy I'm like Define
healthy the only person beating you up
is you if we could just change the
narrative to it's hard comma it's okay I
expect it to be hard why wouldn't it be
hard it would be unreasonable for it to
be easy I wasn't trying to fit into a
cookie cutter of like you have to do
these things this way people Point
externally to the reason that their life
isn't the way they want it to be there
are absolutely things that are
circumstantial that can hurt prevent
decrease the likelihood that you achieve
something comma doesn't affect your
actions so that's not me saying that
those things aren't real it's saying
that what are we going to do about it
comment that's okay is actually just a
representation of like how I think to
myself all the time in accepting current
state rather than trying to create a
discrepancy between where I am and where
I want to be I'm going to do this my way
comma and that's okay period